hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us let's get into it
well it's up on my cannon I'm about to
answer the internet what's the youngest
age child that could beat you up I was
actually speaking about this on my
podcast the other day because we looked
at Mike Tyson when he was 13 years old
and I would I was trying to go down how
young he would have to be to for me to
have a chance at beating him up and I
think Mike Tyson at six and a half years
old I could potentially beat the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of it but that's also
Brownsville Mike Tyson so he was
snatching purses and elbowing old men so
six and a half years old if you only had
five dollars to get drunk what would you
buy mad dog 20/20 baby
that's it you got to buy as many of
those I mean it is also that's the only
alcohol that made me cry in college I
had like three of them and apparently
I've found out that it's like you know
the extra of wine they're trying to make
wine then it's all the extras I miss it
mix it up and I was crying about my dad
for about 45 minutes outside of a frat
party in Geneseo my tears were freezing
to my cheek oh not not to mention I also
used to drink forties of Ivaldi in the
shower I had one in the shower and then
I would have one in my dorm room while I
was getting dressed to go out so I was
primed blackout drunk before the party
even began pretty sure that was under
five bucks
would you take a million dollars to be
one of the picket people for the
Westboro Baptist Church during a fallen
soldiers funeral the first half is
almost like well this is too much and
then you're like during a fallen
soldiers funeral and I'm like absolutely
I am I am anti-war I'm a libertarian we
should withdraw all the troops I already
went there I made them laugh so did my
tour I have a Purple Heart since I got
bit by one of the Marine dogs in Kuwait
that's a true story I volunteered for
that watch my special it's one of the
bits but yeah actually at this point I
feel like being an agitator is a good
comedy credit so I'd probably sell some
tickets
what would you trade a three-year-old
baby for I mean a three-year-old baby is
pretty high-priced on the black market
right so yes that is prime dollar dollar
bills honestly I would have to get some
sort of casino endorsements that level
of cash for a three-year-old white baby
boy yeah I got to to FD r--'s yep yeah
honestly maybe we should revisit this
two-and-a-half years when my kid really
starts pissing me off and I'm like I
should I never had you but yeah I mean
what would I trade you know a years of
rent I'm struggling if you had to pick
one person to be the ambassador for the
human race to meet aliens who would it
be
Lil Wayne I feel like Lil Wayne would
have such an interesting conversation
with them and he also looks like them at
this point I mean lean he knows the
Martian DAP it's just instant I mean at
this point he has done so much
hallucinogens and lean that he has lived
on Mars for the last decade so he's got
as much in common with them as humanly
possible I would either him or Elon Musk
that's you know you Lance for sure part
of it yeah he's also seized on airplanes
which I don't think there's a
coincidence to that the closer he gets
to the mothership the more difficulty
his body has sustaining itself you stay
over at someone's house and when you
wake up you realize you pissed in their
bed do you sneak out or tell them I'll
tell you exactly what happened when this
happened to me I I was on ecstasy and
quite drunk one Halloween I got sent
home early from the bar the the bouncer
actually told me I need to leave the
island of
manehattan he didn't just kick me out of
the bar he kicked me out of the Burrow
I went home got into bed later that
night my wife found me army crawling
into the living room where I forgot six
of my friends and their girlfriends were
staying I climbed into an air mattress
with my buddy spaz and his girl Arry and
on all fours I just started pissing and
he wakes up and he's like dude what are
you doing what are you doing and in the
saddest comedian type way I just looked
at him I god I just want to make people
laugh and I gotta tell you I slept
pretty calmly that night
if someone texted you a picture of your
dick with no context would you know it's
your dick no I don't think so my dick is
most versatile to it there is there are
there are moments where I'm really proud
of it and then there's other moments
where I truly don't believe that it's
attached to a human body so somebody
could sent it to send it to me in that
state and it would just baffle me I
would have no just really no I've never
seen that man or that dick yeah honestly
I'd have an easier time identifying the
pubes then I would the actual penis the
under view of the Kubrick shop that is
good from your balls up I would have no
idea if you gave me a piercing eye level
I've never made eye contact with my own
penis there's no I'd never know it's 500
years from now and you're the person in
charge of naming this era what would you
call it man in 500 years so we've gone
from where we're altra woke I assume the
pendulum is going to swing and two
people are just going to own whites at
some point then it'll probably swing
back the other way it'll be right in the
middle where it's the tan era since
everybody has [ __ ] everybody and we
have no cultural cultural differences
whatsoever we're all the same
no I think that's actually where we
should be heading I am Irish as [ __ ]
dude I am a product of centuries of
inbreeding
so please somebody in my family [ __ ]
somebody tan which would you rather have
been have be random your weekly paycheck
ranging from zero to double your
paycheck or what you eat for dinner
every night is randomized I I mean at
this point my paycheck is pretty random
or it could be real impressive depending
on the month on the road or it could
just be like honey we're eating noodles
and books I but I'm pretty easy with
dinner
I could eat a plate of horseshit and be
totally fine I'm not an Eagles fan but I
could stomach it would you rather
everyone in your girlfriend's office
want to [ __ ] her
or nobody want to [ __ ] her I would want
everybody to want to [ __ ] her because
that means you've made a solid decision
with where your penis gets to dock
comfortably right I mean she doesn't I
mean I assume that's what happens anyway
right if you let your girl outside isn't
that what she's facing accepting who
special in this city just people she
gets up off the subway and somebody
sniffing her seat by the time she's not
even out the door so yeah by all means
wanna [ __ ] my girlfriend would you
rather suck one dick for 50 grand or get
1,000 for every dick you suck I mean I
honestly think I could be 50,000 ex or
50 dicks see I'm saying I'm movin up
I plan on leveling up hardcore 50,000
for one dick to completion or do you
just have to like to completion finish
the job I feel like I could find a few
nerds that could pop off pretty easy and
I'll just run through them I'll just
make them come maybe blindfold them
shave my face so they don't feel the
whiskers I can make it happen
I can get through a tough afternoon
are you a wet or dry masturbator
tell us slow while making eye contact
into the camera eye well I'm always a
wet masturbator because I have clammy
hands so I'm just I'm a sweaty helmet
tickler but I will go with full lotion
when I'm on the road and saying in a
hotel but so often it's like aloe or
menthol and it just like seeps into my
dick hole and it is a rough night would
you rather [ __ ] the hottest girl
celebrity who has a dick or Vin Diesel
with a [ __ ] I mean a hot girl celebrity
with a dick we can go anal she could
tuck it back I can find out if I like
sucking dick it's a nice it's a nice
thing because you're like well I'm not
gay because 95% of her body is not male
but the best part of her is male still
the most active part that I have to
handle it's a little male guys I swear
I'm not gay if you could be a superstar
athlete in any sport but you couldn't
have sex would you do it yeah yeah I
absolutely would I mean I would just be
like a Jordan level sociopaths where I
am racking up millions in either
gambling debt or wins and hopefully my
father gets murdered as well oh no he
didn't want to but I want it I'll put
that out there would you rather live
with your parents for the rest of your
life or always have to use toilet paper
as napkins I feel like all of these
questions are hilarious because it's
like what type of scumbag do you have to
be to consider one of these options and
most of these are about my everyday life
yeah dude I am Kyle I have such look you
could probably see the glisten on my
hands right now I'm gonna go to the
bathroom after this and use toilet paper
just to moist mic just to stop up the
moisture so yeah I would I would rather
live with my parents already I've always
used toilet paper I guess living with my
parents right now would also be a
nightmare they've been they've been
divorced for 12 years
and it would be a straight fisticuffs
fest would you rather have a chick with
a great ass but sideburns or a chick
with great tits but a thin mustache
yeah I'm a I'm an ass guy so I would
rather sideburns and no ass hair you
know as long as there is no this patch
above her around her not there's no
wreath
there's no Christian Christmas wreath
around her [ __ ] I am more than okay
with her having like a Jason Priestley
slight burn she's just dining at the
Peach Pit
you